el miércoles es un día crucial para la
campaña presidencial en francia el
manuel macro en marine le pen se
enfrentarán una vez más en la televisión
en directo pero cuáles son sus
estrategias para el próximo debate
una cosa es segura no querrán que se
repita lo ocurrido en 2017 están ahí en
el campo en los pueblos fue un debate
lleno de insultos que dejó macrón como
claro ganador frente a la candidata de
extrema derecha deja de decir cosas
ridículas pero el cara cara del
miércoles será un reto mayor para el
presidente en funciones la gente está
comparando el debate con el de 2017
todos dirán que le pen ha progresado así
que será positivo para ella le pain se
prepara con simulacros de debate junto a
un experto que encaja con el perfil
político de macrón y el presidente
francés ha tomado nota de los
movimientos del epen para cuidar su
lugar en el elíseo y esto queda
dedicando mucho tiempo para prepararse
todavía estoy amenazado en este debate
es algo realmente serio
ninguno de los dos candidatos quiere que
este sea un debate agresivo pero lepe y
no descarta enfrentarse a macro
crisis y es una ocasión en la que
podamos tener un debate duro y donde se
pueda abordar su trayectoria entonces si
será un momento clave de la campaña
fundamental de la compañía los asesores
del presidente anticipan un ataque
vamos a recibir un golpe tenemos que
desenmascarar la y desentrañar su
programa los 2 candidatos están
preparados para este debate donde todo
está en juego es un cara a cara que será
visto por millones a nivel nacional con
miras a la segunda vuelta del 24 de
abril